the days are back
the church of what's happening now
would like to introduce you to
hellotushy.com hellotushy.com makes
portable devices that spray your butt
clean with water hellotushy.com church
to get 10 off of your order that's
hellotoshi.com church to get 10 off all
of the great bidets
the show is also brought to you by
onyx.com go to onit.com and use codeword
church to save ten percent on all the
amazing optimization products like alpha
brain new mood swim tech moon and shroom
tech sport
the church of what's happening now
monday october 10th
2016.
eliza schlesinger
lee syed
your uncle joey
baby
oh [ __ ]
such a hard song to sing
[ __ ]
if i'm correct this is 81 that's what
you're trying to [ __ ] tell me that's
that's what i that's what they're saying
that's what you're trying to tell me
look this song up for sure all right i'm
almost positive it's 81 because i still
remember hanging out with my undertaker
buddy
and he loved this it's a good song and
he would blast it to the shore the way
back for the shore
well it's one of those songs when i that
i when i decided to sing it i went i
looked up the words and it's one of
those songs that you know you like you
hear it at karaoke and you don't realize
how many words are in the song
such a hard song it's a hard song there
were parts of it when i was thinking i
was like i'm just gonna it's gonna sound
shitty because i can't nor do i have to
but she's it's pretty amazing it was in
81 it was in the movie school of rock i
don't know if that means anything to you
no i just remember this coming out and
then the album belladonna this came out
in an album called belladonna
on this and then she put the first thing
she struck with was tom petty and the
[ __ ] heartbreakers when she
left fleetwood mac
she had it timed
yeah she came out with that uh tom patty
and then she blasted this and then she
dropped belladonna and that was the end
of the [ __ ] game that's like showing
up with two aces got a full [ __ ]
house bam yeah stop dragging my heart
around yeah that was one of the most
played videos on mtv that was one in the
beginning i mean you guys are kids i'm
just letting you know that the whole mtv
scene started right that was one of the
pioneer videos people would wait to see
that i just remember the snl video i was
at snl or living color they did stevie
nicks tacos she was like before she's
like i'm into black magic and witchcraft
oh i also love these tacos it was crazy
and then she blew up to like you know
she got really big
stephen yeah
yeah i like that i just like the song
just the one that rumors uh the album
you've showed me it must have been years
ago it's still one of my favorites 75 oh
my god i was in the eighth grade or
something you know i still remember it
was a girl that was a a national baton
spoiler and she had a party at her house
and we went over there and she's like
you gotta hear this
i'm like what are you talking about
fleetwood mac
and my head almost blew up when she put
on chains
yeah all that [ __ ] stevie nicks did with
them was just brilliant
i never had an education in rock my
parents were divorced and if i asked my
f i told my dad i sang the song
i never liked any of that stevie nicks
[ __ ] he's like he doesn't like that
he's got like original boston records
like three dog night jay and the
americans like that's his thing but i
didn't have a
to understand rock and roll at for my
generation you either have to be
autodidactic or like get an older
brother that taught you about it or your
parents were super into it but i'm from
like the suburbs of dallas texas and i
listen to kiss fm growing up so for me
like i hear all this stuff and i know
it's a part of like the fabric of
american culture i know the songs but
like i'm not a study you know so i
always feel left out i just grew up
listening to the radio there was a radio
station in new york city that if you
wore this needle yeah i was a [ __ ]
geek elijah when i came from cuba so i
bought into the [ __ ] system so wabc
had a button and if you wore the button
and they came up to you you won 25 000
so you had to sit there and listen to
the [ __ ] songs and they would go okay
we're in north hollywood
so me and you would run the north
hollywood with buttons and walk around
like two dinners five thousand whatever
the [ __ ] people never won nothing
they were never even [ __ ] out not one
time that i go thank you for the 25 000.
there's someone out there like we got to
get rid of these buttons yeah no they
were little buttons wabc yeah and they
played
like pop like right like i still
remember listening all night to here
betty and the jets
like that's what was on when i was
growing up like elton john was the
[ __ ] king of music when i was a kid
right and then they would go okay we're
on 72nd street and broadway where are
you that would [ __ ] run down they
weren't
broadcasting remotely from the bathroom
i was a sucker for all that [ __ ] yeah in
1983 [ __ ] mtv had a
uh
uh contest
that if you won you could go to pat
benatar's wedding well my plan
yeah my plan was a wedding to her
wedding invited to her wedding can you
[ __ ] believe this are you flying
there they they do the whole thing mtv
was going to fly you and a guest
would you ever do that eliza for your
wedding have like uh like fans show up
like that seems like something that no
one would know like that's so horrible
you're a brock star you don't have like
a vip section at a wedding
that's terrible [ __ ] pat benatar was
gonna get married in
hawaii and she was gonna have four
people come on the wedding and then
they'd do a private concert on the beach
in hawaii my plan was
to [ __ ] go down there and when they
say there's anybody
have any objections to go [ __ ] crazy
and go bat you can't get married i love
you and just be you know what i'm saying
like that's just this is why you don't
invite fans right to anything nothing
nothing i sent eliza i must have sent
thousands of postcards
who was going to stand up
the picture what's it a postcard of
nothing blank poster letter just you're
describing a letter just a little
[ __ ] postcard that you buy at
stationary stores in the 80s
and it said mtv studios bro box 6450 new
york new york and then on the inside you
had a right joey diaz i want to go to
pat benatar's wedding for [ __ ] every
day i mailed from different posts you
know me i went to different different
angles yesterday i think it was the same
no i kept from every place probably so
many joey diaz i was there i was working
for a bookie in those days so on the way
of course while i was working for the
bookie i'd do the [ __ ] things and
then when i was going back on 118th i'd
mail them from different locations in
the city so if i would go to harlem to
pick up coke i would mail them from all
and before you take it for different
locations they were gonna it's the same
name i don't [ __ ] know elijah because
i'm [ __ ] superstitious do you
understand me when you're super [ __ ]
you gotta work it for my refuge
and it didn't pay off because at the end
i didn't win the [ __ ] contest you
think it's because you didn't stick with
the one mailbox yeah looking back no
because because i'm the kiss of death at
the time if i would send it in today i'd
be front row at beth benitez [ __ ]
wedding what did your friends think of
that like that doesn't seem like
something your friends would be too
supportive of do you think i [ __ ]
told my friends you think i would even
mention that to you we're gonna go and
then be like where are you going you'll
be like wanna make a vacation i'm just
going yeah i'm gonna go around going to
hawaii all expenses paid this happens
these things happen to people i was
gonna take my friend stinky because he
went everywhere with me that's what you
wanted a wedding that's why i wouldn't
have taken him to the wedding i said we
i would have told him we're going to
hawaii
and let him do whatever he'd do and then
i would've got to the wedding by myself
yeah listen when pat benatar is getting
married you can talk any any any woman
on the island to do anything with you
when you're on an island i can walk up
to you and say eliza i'm bored you're
bored my bedtime's getting married you
want to come right you're like you know
what man i'm on vacation you know what
i'm on my honeymoon but let's go yeah
who cares like hon i'm just going to go
with him
where would you like to go for your
honeymoon when the beautiful day
happened i don't know
i you know what and i think you can
attest to this i travel so much as it is
that you don't want to do it i don't
want to do anything i come home
and i'm oh i like you so much you're
like come to the valley in the beginning
of the work week and i was like i'll go
for you but i have family in santa
monica i don't see on like major
holidays it's eliza please explain to
the people when i emailed you you have
an email response that comes back saying
listen
i got a dog it doesn't work out
i write everywhere i dance i'm [ __ ]
busy
okay if i don't get [ __ ] back to you
don't be mad at me this is my
assistant's [ __ ] address send them a
call and i'll get back to you whenever i
love you have a good day god bless you
elizabeth it's the best way to do it the
best way to do it to have it up all the
time you're an [ __ ] but i happen to
be doing a lot of things right now and
i'm on a very
personal basis with everybody that books
me on the shows like i'm not a dick like
i answer stuff a lot of comics like i
never go to your email i answer
everything but i happen to be going
through so many things right now i just
don't want anyone to think that i think
i'm too cool and so it's like better you
know that i'm busy and that your email
will get answered and someone else will
answer it versus just ignoring it have
you ever worked with a professional
writer like someone who's written a
television show [ __ ] somebody big
like a real person like a real person
got somebody let's get together no no no
coffee you ever call these [ __ ]
people
they don't answer their phones nobody
answers the phone block of their day
that they don't answer they'll call you
right back when that block is over but
that's the writing time and that's their
writing time for my friend it's like six
hours some people have that if if what
you have is writing and that's your
thing just like i'm not gonna answer the
phone when i'm on stage but i think in
general like in hollywood it's be it's a
cool thing to act like you're busy
like a lot of male comics like did you
get the text about the show oh i didn't
check it i'm like really well then
where'd the text go [ __ ] like you
have a data plan so i try to just be
cognizant of other people's time and not
make them feel like jerk offs if they
email me or text me there's nothing
worse than when you reach out to someone
and they just don't write back
for like a business thing it makes you
feel like an idiot right
you feel like it's [ __ ] horrible
that's what the whole
my beef is like you i work for eliza in
her movie for a week
that week i could call [ __ ] lives at
three in the morning right and eliza
will answer that [ __ ] phone and go
joey i need you on the set at 7 15 with
that blue shirt on because you're
working together but the [ __ ] that
pisses me off it's sunday when i call
you and there's no more movie and you
don't answer the [ __ ] phone
and that's what has been done to me by
just regular movies that we talk every
day and all of a sudden the movie's done
i call you for something
right three messages
wow
so when i was doing your movie you
answered the [ __ ] phone right the day
after the movie ends i call you for a
check or the paperwork and i these guys
wouldn't call me back for a month right
well
this [ __ ] like that professor that's
really [ __ ] crazy i think for the
traveling i mean yeah that drives me
crazy and i don't you know you hope the
goal is to be respected enough as i'm
sure you are but in general that people
will answer or people feel that you're
important enough to answer back and you
know you remember when people didn't
answer stuff and you remember that kind
of stuff and not that you should make a
list but it sticks with you and all i
made the decision i made the decision a
long time ago that i was not going to
act like my colleagues i was not going
to be no i'm not going to answer
everything on i don't even check
facebook and every email sometimes
they're inappropriate or sometimes it's
i don't know you got this
but i was gonna make an effort to treat
everybody like a person and as long as
you're cool to me i'll try to be cool
back
and that's just a decision i made them
just i'm not the kind of person who just
ignores people i mean a couple years ago
when things started popping like 11
years ago for me
and i started going to these meetings
at every [ __ ] meeting
there was one jerk off that was always
25 [ __ ] minutes late
i just you know when writers want to
meet with you and their managers and how
you might stop the writer like those
meetings and they choose a restaurant or
something right and then your agent has
to go and your [ __ ] manager has to
tag along so everybody's sitting there
with puppy dog guys and this jerk-off
walks in 25 minutes later hey guys so
sorry so so there's so much traffic
ventura i've got a kid oh my [ __ ] oh
my god
somebody came to me like a really top
comic one day i was telling my situation
he goes nah you're getting it all wrong
he goes when you're a comedian man
you always gotta be like
is he black
and i go
no a white successful comic who is it
and i go he goes you you have to be late
that's what it means to
put the work in and otherwise i gotta
tell you something i did it one time and
i was like
no he's wrong no please i grew up
different i grew up completely different
15 minutes early and i'm going to get so
much [ __ ] for the black thing whatever
like i'm the only person
it's it really is about the way you were
raised but and i've said this on my own
podcast
so you see successful comics right and
people start to act a cert everybody
knows people start to act a certain way
when they're successful and then what
happens is comics who have not put in
that time those are their buddies or
those are the people that they you know
that they look up to so they're like oh
if i act like an [ __ ] then it looks
like i'm cool and it kind of works
having like a little bit of swag but i'm
like but you don't have 20 minutes to
back it up to me you just seem like a
dick i'd rather just do my job well
absolutely and be cool just because i'm
never late i was here early i watched
you eat all the mushrooms i get i cannot
my dad says if you're not early you're
late
and i just think it's it's disrespectful
other people's time and it's just not a
way to do business no i didn't like i
was like why would i be late when i
that's against my [ __ ] principle no i
won't be late like that's against
everything i [ __ ] believe you know
what if you have a meeting at one leave
it 12 15 if it takes 15 minutes and
that's the other it's like oh so you
don't know how to
get download a waze app and it's so
funny because especially in hollywood
it's cool to be late it's cool to come
in late not show up before i was late
and what shocks me i always think like
but wait a minute but at one point in
your life you were on time you were on
time to the audition that got you this
show that turned you into an [ __ ] you
were on time for your costume fitting
you were on you've been on time for
things before so it isn't as if the
concept of time just eludes you you know
to be on time you're just choosing not
to
because i don't matter have you guys
ever had someone cancel a meeting or
something when you're there on time and
then they're late and then they cancel
it when they're late and they're not
even there i have not had that happen oh
i had i i was doing a podcast for
somebody and we got down there we were
at his house
not the guy's house but the guest house
and like 15 minutes after he was already
texting around the corner around the
corner he's like oh i can't do it today
i was like oh
that sounds like a bad date oh it was
i've never had a date do that i've never
thought that was i've never had that
either
uh i try not to have uh meetings unless
they're absolutely necessary also
something i've learned recently the more
the busier you are and the more valuable
your time is no i don't have time to
grab a [ __ ] coffee and catch up i had
somebody the other day they're like when
are we going are you busy friday i'm
like that is prime real estate for
[ __ ] i don't have that's my pr like
i'm gonna do my set and then go out with
someone i love or care about not you not
for dinner with a general meeting you're
out of your mind to ask for a friday or
saturday night are we married
no
no coffee even and then there's actually
no time to have a meeting coffee in the
middle of the day it's like so i have to
stop everything i'm doing to go force a
coffee to hear your like cartoon idea
i'm just saying i don't have a schedule
neither do you no neither
thisly there's two types of people
there's people that have a schedule
there's people that don't have a
schedule if i wanted a [ __ ] schedule
i would get a [ __ ] day job yeah
so i don't have a schedule my schedule
is 7 24
and i don't know when the [ __ ] i'm
working yeah and i
i don't know if i could do a [ __ ]
lunch
i don't know if i could do a coffee i
don't know it changes too like the whole
day today i didn't even i have i'm
supposed to take headshots or something
tomorrow
and i thought my daughter was sick
tomorrow so i would have to be around
the house
i don't think she's going to stay home
now so now i didn't call the guy tonight
so now i'm the [ __ ] i got to call the
guy he's gonna call the guy because he
probably rented a studio
no no he has he does it out of his home
it's for ciso
yeah no i i could shoot it after the i
shoot there's no rush yeah there's no
your head's not changing well they're in
a rush but they're always in a rush but
they're in a rush but yeah they're
always by the way you're gonna rush
you're going to kill yourself to get
these headshots and then they won't come
out for like two months right december
8th can i just scan this out yeah yeah
yeah yeah no there's i don't play the
game either i tell them it's by the day
well i always that's always my point of
contention with anything is
it's sort of the same idea that like i
was like i'm batting a thousand i'm the
one working hard so when someone else
like it's always like you've got to do
this you've got to do this so i rush and
i make four shows or i make that flight
or i get together this set and then
they're like okay we're just gonna mull
it over i'm like oh i'm really glad i
snapped my back in half so you guys can
just chill out and take a dump feels
great i'll just go [ __ ] myself
did you start in dallas i didn't i
started here what
what is it so you moved here and started
fresh i started all by myself
fresh here i went to school in boston
and i started here what college did you
go to into emerson me too yeah oh yeah
yeah that's why that's why you're in
production last year yeah i was two
years bumping through each other no he's
five years younger than me wow and then
it was funny i actually turned down a
job it was right as i was getting into
the industry i almost worked on your
show what show the the dating show
excuse yes oh really
that show was crazy like i i worked in
post forever and well not in three years
but your show was crazy because they
shot like every day for like three
months oh 100 episodes we shot
230 episodes one a day we shot for two
seasons
it was a gauntlet
like i am equipped for any hosting job
because i shot that many episodes like
there's no one that has more aired hours
on tv hosting unless you've been on like
a show for like five years 230 in two
years and like one year or something so
one show fountain any days uh we treat
for a couple months each summer we did
it for two years we had two seasons 230
episodes total one a day so 115 episodes
and one shot
one hour never called in sick no day off
you get your weekends off but
all day every day from about
june to october and how long did you
have to be there all day
nine to nine all day i get there
eight or nine what's all that you do
your hairy makeup you come down i film
the first act and the people that go on
their dates i go to lunch i'd come back
we'd shoot the middle part where someone
got eliminated or excused excuse me
branding and then i a little bit later
that afternoon or night or early evening
is when the elimination part and i would
like literally bolt offset and jump in
my car to make it to the comedy store by
9 45 or not depending on what it was and
they never gave me an inch of wiggle
room i'd be like i am running from a tv
show that i'm on and they'd be like well
if you're gonna miss your spot
and i'm just like can someone give me a
[ __ ] break and i would bolt out of
there every night to try to make it
wherever the spots were
but uh yeah that was the that's the [ __ ]
i can't like that
it's uh it's funny working on that on
the other side of tv especially when you
have because you've done a couple
specials and then with what joey was
talking about like they're really
anxious for the for these pictures but
these pictures they're just anxious
because it's on a to-do list right and
there's no there's no real
angle like it used to kill me when the
network or the the head of the
production company would come in because
stuff would be cleaned moved around
right they'd put the best people up
front it was crazy it's uh it's a it's a
crazy experience to go through
just seeing how like who they really
care about
yeah
why i hate the whole hurry up and how
open weight i've been here for too long
and i know how it works so i i know the
things that you use tango
where's the logic in this well there is
none but i don't think most people that
make art are logical people and those
who can't create good art go into
production
and that's why it's so scattered i mean
there's so many things going on but any
set you go on you have one line like
we're gonna need you all day you're like
okay but do you okay i already did the
line i need to stay
um about one line on spider-man to
14 [ __ ] days oh oh my god oh from
everything six to midnight it's almost
not even worth it let me tell you what i
would do at six o'clock i would just
[ __ ] hide
yeah
that's that seemed very productive and i
would see the production assistants like
oh what's going on they're like
they haven't said no like they don't say
no
don't say that i would just be prepared
i'd bring tvs oh you got to be prepared
and see dvds you sit in your trailer at
a long distance phone though they put me
in the back of sony in the apartments i
feel like you told me they got
appointments back there yeah there are
tremendous couches that pull out like
they were there like from world war ii i
don't know but we did them yeah the
showers i mean guys it was bigger than
this it's nice yeah bigger than this
door couch opens well here's the thing
cause you're saying you're saying i'm
hiding they don't want you the less
people on set the better well they would
raymie would always go listen joey
you're too big for the [ __ ] train
i can't have you in this [ __ ] train
right so do me a favor just go to the
trailer and wait for like call you and i
would
drink uh
what's that [ __ ] juice that was like
22 bottles
yeah i mean it was the best super yeah
it was the best
it was the best
food movie i've ever been on right i
mean they had tables upon tables upon
tables of just breakfast stuff yeah
locks bagels oatmeals
you know french toast all those juices
all the coffees
start by i mean they just had everything
lunches they paid you 25 bucks to go get
your own lunch but they brought in lunch
right fridays with steak and lobster
tails
so this is my option that i could sit in
my [ __ ] apartment in hollywood and
come up with creepy ideas
or i could sit down there and make scale
blessings a lobster yeah
you know well yeah you go you do the
work you show up yeah but it's still
like okay i showed up on time i go up to
the the directors and go what do you
think today's the day not today joey
we'll call you when we need you then
they would call me
just to introduce me to someone what was
the line
can i hear the line
surely if you want to get to him
you got to go through me
that's it that's it that's what someone
wrote
that's what someone stole from someone
else like forty thousand dollars for
that [ __ ] line and that was that's
great with no residuals that's great can
you believe that you don't deserve
residuals
i fired the manager that told me don't
do that movie that's for one day scale i
wouldn't do it right harvey fierstein
was your manager oh no no it was some
chick that thought she was badass i have
a i have a similar this is
there was no scale involved the i went
to creative arts camp
when i was 14 and they you know at
creative arts camp you do one audition
and then they put you in a play there's
like 10 different plays and they just
place you however they do it and then
throughout the summer there's other
plays they were putting on our town by
thornton wilder anyway i was so excited
because i was going to creative arts
camp coming from dallas texas all the
kids from are from new york and los
angeles i was like where was the camp in
upstate new york okay i was like this is
it like this is when i get a chance
to be somebody and i audition and they
put me in our town and i get the part of
a lady in the balcony which is a person
who sits in the audience
and during part of the play the narrator
pretends that he's at a town hall
meeting and he goes to the audience for
questions and i have to sit in the
audience the entire duration of the play
and i stand up and i have to say is
there much culture in grover's corners
that's the name of the town they live in
that's my whole line and that's what
like i spent the whole summer for this
one play
and so i go to high school the next year
on the first day of school i look at
this at the phone play and it's gonna be
our town and i was like i [ __ ] got
this i'm gonna play the lead i've
watched her all summer i or at least
i'll get i'll be the mother i'll be a
cow i'll be something i read for it i
get laid in the balcony again
the same [ __ ] line
two years in a row so don't give up kids
could you recite that play word for word
i can resign that line word for word no
i mean like after sitting in the balcony
for the influence no but the second time
i was like [ __ ] this i'm not paying
attention
you guys can go to hell i'm gonna make
out with my hot boyfriend you know i
didn't know movies
i watched movies yeah i went to movies
but when i moved out here i didn't know
dick
and scott
he was one of the best talent
coordinators as a comedy store had he
was
a guy that was really good looking
you thought
he was straight but he was gay as hell
he drank
more
than anybody i've ever seen
for a guy that size okay and he kept it
together he was a functioning [ __ ]
wild man at the store
to the point where i remember one monday
i brought him he got me a gig and he was
can i give you a commission on this it
was like my first 750 dollar gig yeah
i'm like scott i have to give you scott
day
he lives like in [ __ ] africa now
amongst elephants and [ __ ]
he moved here with louis anderson okay
good looking dude and
i brought him a bottle of [ __ ] like
expensive tequila at 12 o'clock when he
got there
you know by nine o'clock the bottle was
[ __ ] gone and he was standing there
talking to me about politics and comedy
and [ __ ] i'm like this is not even
reeking of tequila right
maybe spill it huh maybe he spilled it
no this [ __ ] and then he would
sit there and drink and watch the axe
till about 10 15. yeah he would wait for
mitzi and then once he got there he
would leave comedy store is a very
special place
scott day i forgot i don't even know
what the moral of the [ __ ] story was
he said he was a good talent a talent
booker whatever it's called talent
coordinator
yeah why i brought it up who the [ __ ]
knows
it's just great to have you here i'm
happy i like having women on the podcast
and it's tough to get them on sometimes
well it's a scary neighborhood is it
really scary i did not want to get out
of the vehicle i thought you knew it i
thought you knew it for some reason or
another i know where we i mean i know
they i know the area
i know oh boy you would have hated the
other place where we were at was it up
the block
up second floor real creepy we walked
out one night and there was a guy laying
there
and the ladies tell him you gotta call
the cops listen lady knox the next day
he goes that guy was making believe he
was asleep when i went to the bathroom
he robbed my purse and he ran out of
here or something
like where are you oh my god at night i
would [ __ ] my pants walking down the
stairs and walking out of there and go
why do i do the podcasting yeah no i
don't know then we found this place and
this is cool
there was a girl downstairs that had a
real popular podcast that's how i found
this place and i came and asked if i
could have it when she went to rotten
tomatoes now she's just [ __ ] cnn
but she started downstairs right in this
office right there it's important to
have a space yeah you can do it at your
house but it's good especially for
comics to have a place to go to
so this is good
it's lovely inside what's up lee how are
you feeling i'm feeling fine so far
mushroom sure why not sure what the [ __ ]
face is as red as your t-shirt oh yeah
you both look like you're about to cry
no not yet
no i'm good i could pay today it was
nice and easy yeah and do [ __ ] it was
fun where were you last weekend
i wasn't anywhere last uh we finished
oddball
right now the oddball where'd you go but
i didn't i didn't go anywhere
i didn't go anywhere i came from new
york
then i did oddball i didn't go anywhere
and then this weekend i'm in denver
and it sold out so i think there's like
one show on friday that's left
but this is comedy works this comic
works um but not in larimer square the
suburbs beautiful i haven't been ever
i've always played the larimer square
one and i'm a little sad because i i
really enjoy it i really enjoy that club
i know john caparillo's there and he's
so funny so i graduated up to the the
one in the suburbs and so i'll go do
that and then my tour my theater tour
starts november like fourth
and this is promoting then netflix
russia netflix the tour starts with that
we had to talk about t-shirts and stuff
today um but yeah and then
that's it how many theaters are you
doing on this channel there's 14
and what size of the theaters
a couple thousand good for you fourteen
fourteen hundred fourteen hundred
percent two thousand probably definitely
not over 2000
and then hopefully we'll do a second leg
in like europe
really you want to go and give it a shot
yeah i did london once and that was
great so you know all like the
english-speaking places and maybe even
like sweden because i think they're
really into comedy they're really into
comedy that's pablo francisco's joy oh
my god i think he's so funny that's
pablo's joint up there he goes every
year
i know he was going there maybe eight
years ago for a hundred grand for one
show or something
so by now he probably goes there twice a
year for a million and he's fine i
remember doing the
south african comedy festival and pablo
francisco was on it was me and trevor
noah before he was anybody and he was
lighting it up on stage there and some
of the jokes were in afrikaans and some
of it was and some of the stuff i didn't
know what he was talking about because
it was like a lot of like local stuff
but he was on and that's how i met him
and i saw pablo at breakfast and i was
like can i sit with you like and he was
super cool about it and i just remember
he's one of the comics that i
sort of that i
look up to is weird because i don't
really know him but that i definitely
take a page from his book
and he's not the most famous but he's so
[ __ ] good and you say his name people
like who is that and i'm like oh because
you only know like the three comics that
are on netflix it's probably francisco
for days when i moved to this town
little pigeons when i moved to this town
he was on [ __ ] fire
in fuego i'm 97 when i first went to the
last factory latino night
i had like a five-minute spawn they said
pablo francis goes on watch this this
was like maybe the either seinfeld yeah
and he did each one of them in [ __ ]
spanish oh
okay standing ovations yeah people
puking because it was just
it was just pure brilliance it was just
the [ __ ] jerry seinfeld in spanish
and from there it just didn't stop he's
one of the kind he's one of the first
comics where someone comes over and i'm
lucky because people tell me they do
this with my comedy now and it's so it's
so gratifying but people come over i'd
be like watch this clip come watch this
youtube clip and he had the bit about
pigeons uh have like you could say
anything to a stripper and she'll agree
with you oh look pigeon she's like [ __ ]
yeah little pigeons
i look apples [ __ ] yeah green apples
he's like it's gonna happen she likes
apples anyways verbatim that's the clip
you can uh youtube it but he was great
what year was that were those specials
because that's how when i first saw him
like his comedy central special you know
i don't remember
let me look at him
yeah check it out
because that like that was he a store
comic
yeah he's got a yeah
but i don't know he just contacted me i
didn't know it was him he left me a
message to be on the podcast oh my god i
saw him at the ice house and we had a
great talk it was great to see him
he's one of the best guys in comedy
comedy wise and as generous as can be
when i was when i first got to this town
he would hire me in different cities and
he would pay me above and beyond like i
would go are you crazy yeah you know
he's always been a great guy john
panetta was like that with me i know
he's gone
my one of my first gigs to feature they
flew me to las vegas i didn't know who
he was and he asked me are you a vegas
comic i said no i'm from l.a he's like
how much should it cost you to get here
i told him you know probably with room
and everything was around and
uh they paid me 500
and i spent most of it to get there
and then he was like come to my office
on monday and i'll write you a check and
i went to his office and his
his manager larry shapiro wrote me a
check for 500
so i had the money i'll never forget
that he did that and it was a real when
you start in comedy
you learn how to treat other comics by
how kind comics are to you and i don't
know that comics ever gave me a real
break but once in a while when someone
is kind like that it sticks with you and
like pablo was cool when i met him he
won't remember me you know but like the
comics who aren't dicks then you're like
oh that's the way to treat people
one time i was in houston
and pablo called me at like 11 in the
morning on a saturday he goes what are
you doing do you want to go to the mall
i don't know i got to meet these people
for lunch because all right that night i
saw him he gave me a bag he bought him
three shirts at the mall oh on a
saturday like i'm talking about [ __ ]
shirts like i was like bomb are you
serious he got me like a laker
for lure thing but i really couldn't
wear you know what i'm saying
it was like too much it was like purple
with the dark black right if you put it
on you lost 15 pounds right because you
could there was no oxygen going in there
like there's no uh right can couldn't
breathe there was no you couldn't
breathe right
and he gave me his two other dress
shirts they had to be like 200 a piece
man
yeah unless he took me that saturday you
know i mean it was just uh he's just a
great kid all around yeah it's really
this comic that i worked with this
weekend
the guy that featured me this weekend
i was in columbus
and he's a writer and
20 whatever years ago i used to open for
him how weird
he had just won san francisco
this guy's a dangerous [ __ ] on
stage dangerous his name is rick kearns
he had radio in denver he'll be at the
sh he'll be at the shows
he'll have one of the nights okay
and when you see him the first couple
minutes
he won't be on my shows but no you're
bringing your own people it was so weird
that's why then they're scary because
they throw those headliners at you from
denver oh i don't care no no but they
usually do like a lot of people go to
them i don't i don't you know what i was
saying i don't bring nobody to them
i never did because i always believed in
cultivating local comics and giving
people chances that being said
denver and i love comedy works it's the
only city where because they give you
different comics every day
they've never been cool never rude but
they come in they do their thing they
don't make eye contact they leave i'm
like
do you realize how much it would behoove
you to just say hi to me all my features
that i bring on that i bring on my tour
and that i work with are people who
featured for me
i liked them as people
and i was like come work for me and they
it was never rude i definitely had
it was never it was just kind of like
almost like they're making a point of
not giving me the respect of talking to
me like i was coming to work i don't
talk to her and it's just like okay it's
your funeral you don't have to do it i
won't help you that's totally fine it's
really [ __ ] weird so this year i'm
playing a different part of the club and
i was like i'm bringing my own people
done i had somebody will i have friends
that will fly in and spend money
to get to do it and i'm not going to use
a local guy who's not going to look me
in the eye and say hi
so
i try to cultivate also
i also uh
you know there's a lot of comics that
you taking the comic on the road
maybe something small to you but
something i remember how big it was for
me when somebody called me at the comedy
story so you're available tuesday what
if i gave you 750 seven [ __ ] fifth
yeah i need to go do my act in wisconsin
and test it out there 100 oh my god so
many comics made my week you know yeah
i mean one night i seen louis ck when i
was hosting
i used to host on sunday yeah and he
came here
together i'm like yeah i got him on
when he got off he goes hey man what are
you doing this week i go
yeah nothing i'm around he goes i wrote
something
i'll know tomorrow give me your number
listen you know i went back on stage i
didn't go home and go honey i got rent
money right
he [ __ ] called and he put me on the
[ __ ] show and i never forgot them
because of that
it's it's a small it's really weird but
it's also like you got him on the show
like you were cool all you had to do was
be a little cool
and he was cool back if you were like no
man can't get you on or hey man you
gotta wait you know like
you gave him a green light people don't
realize like for headliners like you
being cool to us is just as important as
us being cool to you you have to make
people want to do you favors you have to
you know nobody wants to help somebody
who walks into a green room that's a
dick
you know last two years ago a kid hit me
up he goes can i do a guest spot
i go i gotta be honest i really don't
know you i always say
and if i'd say yes
then every show i do i do they're to be
there
like if if you let it's really i was
it's really weird why is it
the word gets out oh you mean other
people come so i like you ever i used to
do a room in bray
and i was very generous with the room
you know i i went home with 50 bucks i
broke it into a three-man show i hosted
i brought a headline and a feature
you know how many times i showed up down
there and there'd be six guys
i didn't know you did comedy here really
what the [ __ ] do you think we do here
right and then they would start we think
in eight minutes the name is turned into
12 and 15.
you know they're [ __ ] savages
so
it got to the point where you know
when i'm going into a town on tuesday i
get home and i got eight facebooks
six of those hey my name is
peter whatever yeah yeah how can i i
can't i don't know just not check it
well how can i how can what if you go on
stage and this kid goes i'm [ __ ] this
is my impersonation of hitler's jerking
on i don't [ __ ] know right i'm trying
to be kind and that's what happens when
you be kind okay here's the other side
of it first of all i don't check the
facebook messages because but sometimes
you know someone if you for the mo i'm
gonna hate that says if you ask me for
something i will usually give it to you
stage time wise and i will have friends
that'd be like hey i'm happy to be in
phoenix that weekend i'll be like you
can have a guest spot i give those out
like candy because it cost me nothing it
means so much to you and that's like a
motto that i live by um i always figure
chances are you're not gonna be a maniac
on stage if you're great then it pumps
up the energy for the show and if you
suck i look amazing
and it's only a couple minutes out of my
life so i give people the chance to do
that it's never come back to bite i hate
what comes with it
there's a thousand situations okay
you see me at the store three nights a
[ __ ] week yeah when i see you i go
hey can i walk the other way i'm never
giving you a hug i never give you the
respect you deserve
now all of a sudden
you're a stand-up live yeah and guess
who wants to buy me a drink and give me
a hug joey diaz and he wants to guess it
[ __ ] you okay but it's oh there's a
thousand of those here's the other side
there's another okay but the other side
for let me say this for you because
you've been doing this longer than me
right yeah i guess how long have you
been doing 25 okay so
a lot longer than me i think that
and you're getting you've hit this
stride now but there are so many years
put in where there was p there were
people ignoring you like that and you
don't seem you're not a mean guy at all
but i think you've had more time to go
through that to have that and now you're
like yeah [ __ ] you you've looked at me
forever
so you're allowed to feel that way i
wouldn't begrudge you that i also will
say this before i met you
i'll never forget the day that you said
hi to me you were so nice and you're
like hey sweetheart and you treated me
like we'd known each other forever and i
just played along because a i was like
have i met him before and b
i you're scary looking and so i always
no i don't know and you're like tough
and
and so i never said anything because i
always figured you were in a different
group of comics and we didn't know not
in like a shitty way so and i get people
like i think i'm a pretty nice person i
get people that won't talk to me because
they're like i'm afraid of you
and it's just it comes with an air you
know and it's people's perception and
they're wrong and you're you're the
nicest
i was like the comments you came up and
said hi i'm gonna tell you [ __ ]
something well but my point is um you're
of course you could feel that way no no
no the amount of people that have been
like i'm afraid like i would feel
something i'd be like you never talked
to me or said hi the amount of people
that are afraid versus not respectful
you know when somebody's i'm afraid you
know this assembly's not respected
you know it you know you said things to
me that you like that but you know when
somebody's not giving you the props
eliza deserves you for for sure okay so
but i do give people the benefit of the
doubt sometimes you know what what if i
would have saw you at the improv and i'm
gonna never saw your last comment
standing i wouldn't have said hello to
you right first off before i met you i
had this woman respect for you
now when i see a girl
like you
that is petite you're none thank you
you're not violent you're not
drunk right you're not obnoxious and i
see you at the store
i feel for you
i feel for you and i want you to know
that i got your back
okay i got your back just in case if
anything goes down i'm not here to hit
on you i'm too [ __ ] old i'm not here
to give you drugs
you have offered me drugs
i'm not here to give them to you i often
do it's just so weird when i'm at the
store i know what girls are faking the
funk
what does that mean
there's girls that go down there fake
the [ __ ] what is fake the funk they show
up for two years they see what they work
then they disappear and then i know a
girl that you like you had this four set
tonight i go to the improv to do a set
there you are and i go to comedy stone
you're like dog [ __ ] you're everywhere
so i found out you were at the i o or
you were at this guy's bar or you do the
seven o'clock show at the comedy store
you work at this it's not like you're uh
dating guys and right uh dating with you
they manage no right you're one of these
[ __ ] that i see out there
banging it and you're running against a
round man my mom was a bookie
and she ran oh my god my mom was a
bookie and she ran around men and when
you see that gift not a lot of women
could do that again thank you it takes a
certain woman with a certain type of uh
self something to walk into a room with
men and not get [ __ ] attacked like
eight guys like me in the room going 604
82 [ __ ] dollars hey what happened
with that guy he never paid you that
money so here you come in with you
looking good you know what i'm saying
like i respect you so that's why the
first time i saw you
i just wanted to let you know that oh
you were so nice these [ __ ] jerk
gloves i got you i i remember you said
hi and i walked when i was like oh joey
diaz knows who i am no i watched it i
watched you i i talked to dan about you
i knew you were tight with joe and i had
i had left the store
and i had just heard about you as i was
leaving you were taken over
so i always talk to hari yeah and uh
i just you know i told you that
before i leave the [ __ ] house not
tonight i didn't but because nobody's
gonna be on tonight
probably some politicians oh you check
all the stores although i check all the
shows i check jimmy fallon i checked
the other [ __ ] guy with the people in
the car
i checked i checked the [ __ ] whatever
and i see what stand-ups are going to be
on there's some stand-ups that i don't
even know and i watch just because i
don't know about young the one guy that
killed me one night was kumanji mananji
kumail nanjiani that [ __ ] about coney
island five years ago [ __ ] i almost
puked that very funny yeah and then you
know there's a few people i'm not gonna
say how many times i've sat up to watch
a showtime special and
throwing the [ __ ] remote off the tv
you're a [ __ ] bum you really had the
balls to open with that joke i heard
that joke eight ten years ago you're
gonna i you know so i'm cheering for the
comments
and then when i see him i want to go up
to him and go now you know what
now you know why you're not getting
spots because how you know but i can't
so i always go if i had the opportunity
to do that so i'm watching the [ __ ]
tonight show and that's elizabeth i get
home
i got the cat on top of me you know
i just smoked a joint i probably had
some peanut butter and jelly and all of
a sudden
i fast forward because i taped it and
you came out and just
it's like you had no fear
you just were laying into them laying
into you're pointing at him even jimmy
fallon was like what the [ __ ] going on
it was just and then he came out and it
was just a big to-do at the end
and i got right on [ __ ] twitter and i
go eliza you [ __ ] them up
god damn it my wife's like why is the
[ __ ] light on in the office i'm
trying to sleep i'm trying to save i go
i gotta take i gotta hit it just she did
really well
and i hadn't seen you since then to pull
you over you're always on the move
you're always on the [ __ ] move so i i
don't want to grab you by the arm and go
listen man i saw you on jimmy fallon and
you [ __ ] them up
but then you said something to me you
know we live in this
comedy world now that women aren't
getting enough spots there's jerk owners
that say women aren't [ __ ] funny
every time
i hear a jerk off saying women aren't
funny i want to send them a clip of lucy
or ball
just to get the party started like this
how wrong you are okay this lady lives
on tv every [ __ ] day for the last 80
years yeah and you're gonna come up with
something it's antiquated some fun thank
you antiquated antiquated that's the
word i was looking for i i feel you know
not to make it about girls because like
you said like i've been
competing against men since i made my
professional
debut or whatever in comedy i did last
comic standing that was all guys comedy
store is mostly guys
so of course if i audition for something
it's me versus another girl but when i
go on tour and i look at if i'm playing
clubs it's all it's men on those rosters
and there's no
this isn't saying bad things about other
girls and i hope they have great careers
but for me it's always been me pitted
against men and then people for
sensationalism be like what about the
other girls and i've just never looked
at that as a competition because
it's me versus another guy to see who
gets a 945 spot at the comedy store you
know
and uh
and the whole women isn't funny women
have been doing so many funny things for
the especially in the last couple years
and comedy's been really hot people
don't say women aren't funny anymore and
if they do i'm like oh there's something
wrong with you oh you're stupid versus
when i first started my career i had to
be like well you know girls are funny
i'm trying to
so now i just i don't even answer it
right
just uh it's just all these
things that these formulas people had
for a long time i'll never forget they
were shooting showtime showtime about 10
years ago
maybe 12 years ago gave away eight half
hours
and they had showcases at the store
and i'll never forget that i'm out there
one night i didn't showcase they were
showcasing a bunch of like up and coming
comics and [ __ ] and i was there one
night and
messina was there rick messina good guy
great guy i you know talked to him all
the time out there
and some girl was talking to him and
she's like you know
i'm having a hard time he's like how old
do you and she's like dirty and he goes
you should just move back to where you
came from
and he goes everybody knows that you
know a woman's hot from
22 to 21 to 27 and
guys after that now here i am long in
the [ __ ] tooth i didn't get it i was
32 i didn't get on stage so i was 30 or
something
and he's like and guys are dead after
25. what's he talking about and i'm
listening to this and i get in my car
and i go home
and that night i'm sitting there and the
next week i saw him up there hey can i
talk to you for a second
because he's a cool guy he's a really
cool guy yeah and i go hey man yeah i
heard you talk to this girl you were
telling me this and this and this [ __ ]
reason you got that baseball field in
your back [ __ ] yard is because of
the two old guys in comedy
uh
tool time
time he was not [ __ ] 28 when he made
it
all right and the other guy with the
glasses
the chubby guy the hostess carry drew
carey he was another guy was 40 when he
[ __ ] made it
i go you made millions off these guys
how can you tell it right he goes you
know it's crazy
i thought about it when i went home that
night what a mistake i made too oh good
he goes i i didn't know what i was
thinking you made millions of dollars
off two [ __ ] old guys especially
comedy you can be older in comedy it's
actually one of the few things where
when you're older people value your
opinion more comedy doesn't discriminate
you're either funny or you're not
whether you get into it later or you
know regardless i'm so [ __ ]
embarrassed right now why like i just
i feel like just
being too old and being on stage
but then the other day we were watching
a rodney clip and i'm like he was
[ __ ] old i watched most of that
special this weekend but you but you
have the gravitas when you get up there
and you say something you know you
mispronounce kumail's name or something
or you say you know
because of who you are and where you're
from and the generation you have it's
okay there are things that i was talking
to joe about this when we left because i
was laughing we were in the car in
arizona and we were hungry and the only
thing that was open is papados and you
were going on you're like you trust your
uncle joey i'm like i don't really know
you you trust your uncle joey go to
papados and then you made a joke and you
were like you're lucky when you get the
gumbo and the sauce with the fingernails
and the katrina oil and i was dying
laughing if i on stage the other night
it said one katrina reference and they
went ice cold but you say it and it's
okay
and granite's about intention something
like that but it's also about like a
life lived there are things you can say
that i can't
and so you shouldn't be embarrassed i
turned the month of the day i will give
you a pep talk i didn't get to try it
this is still about papadopoulos and not
the moral of my story
oh i got po boy but i was i was doing
another one that's not stoned here by
the way yeah which is why we're talking
about papados now but then
like i think why it comes across like
why people are okay with it is because
it's what you say in real life like he
had that entire speech for the server at
papados yeah like he tells everybody
but it's also you know people need are
so [ __ ] pc you're an equal
opportunity offender there's no hate in
your heart
you're just saying and it's just like
this east coast ball breaking like i
know guys like that it's okay
i'm cuban but i got a jewish cup okay so
jewish cup yeah that means you got a
jewish cranium so
all right
i had a friend that used to go
i'm italian but i got a french cup
that's why i know how to make all these
cocktails and he used to kill me he was
like 70
anyway
what the [ __ ] are we talking about we
gotta throw me on i was talking about
your character you started talking about
no no no no no
you're cuban with a jewish hat cup cup
he was talking about papados and i was
saying you have the the the gravitas to
say what you want to say
i [ __ ] forgot that i got to stop
smoking pot maybe a little maybe
a little
i was saying it's okay you were saying
you're ashamed to be old
on stage
how old are you 53. thank god because i
didn't know and i was like what if he
says he's 40 and i gotta tell him he
looks terrible for 40.
a little girl at the house
and she's going to click on the [ __ ]
youtube and he'll have these
conversations it's just a lot of things
that are eating away at me little by
little yeah but she's going to hear
whether you stopped doing it or not
she's pretty happy she you got a minute
she's not going not in today's world you
know
not with that [ __ ] computer
i went over the other night to pick up a
shirt and she came up and she said hi
but then she has a tablet thing
apparently yeah and like i was trying to
say goodbye she's like no goodbye
goodbye like she she she like really
seems to like me but now she's like when
she's had the teal though
oh she loves that [ __ ] tablet so what
are you gonna do with that guy what's
happening branch
blanche doesn't care
she's going as a lobster no it was real
i forgot what i was gonna [ __ ] tell
you it bothers me about the the cuban
with the jewish cup we were talking
about we're talking about you and
attention we're trying to
oh okay i'm so sorry okay so katrina
happened
right all right so
let's pretend you went down to the sea
to the sea let's pretend you went down
there with to see what was going
on they met the ocean and i was thinking
like wait a second
wait just one [ __ ] minute here
look at all this oil look at all these
animals
i seen that commercial for dove right
where they take the [ __ ] bird they
watch the duck and [ __ ] what if i
[ __ ] get like a
or whatever and scoop up all this [ __ ]
take it home and wash it and freeze it
and then once the [ __ ] shrimp thing
goes out i'll sell the shrimp what are
you talking about i'm telling you this
is how you have to think this is not the
way this is somebody did this this is
somebody [ __ ] did there's no katrina
oil in the gumbo listen to me somebody i
didn't say that was listen somebody went
scooped up all these animals with oil on
them what animals the the birds
put them in the gumbo listen to me and
they washed them down really good
without but don with dawn right
and they they washed them down even
though the animals were dead you have
like sacrificed stab you you have 24
hours to get to the hospital and get
stitched up after 24 hours you can't get
stitched up there's nothing i can do for
you
that's like if you get it cut you can't
stitch it after 24 hours that was what
that was 20 years ago i don't know but
i'm pretty sure we could no you have to
look it up the 24 hours you have to
stitch up a wool if not it's two you
can't there's no stitching
you just open one the rest of your life
nah they do
butterflies and [ __ ] like that stitching
you know what i'm saying with [ __ ]
bandages
so the same thing so the shrimp is dead
he's got oil on them i wash them off i
wash them off really nice
i scrub them down
yeah and then i freeze them yeah and i
come to you two years and i got that
shrimp
[ __ ] crust i got shrimp i got shrimp
i like greens and i let me ask you this
and i as a corporate buyer
for that's in charge of food quality for
a
mega chain restaurant
i buy this shrimp out of the back of
your chevy i didn't say that i said that
let's pretend
but this is your conspiracy theory no
there's no conspiracy theory i used to
live this [ __ ] i used to do it i'm
telling you not with katrina fish okay
but fish that fell off oh this is two
different things then same thing this is
fish that fell off a [ __ ] all i gotta
do is tell you
this is shrimp that fell off a thing
you're a gumbo guy you make a living off
the bottom line right correct the mundo
first of all we're gonna bang this out
two ways i'm gonna take that [ __ ]
katrina shrimp and i'm gonna mix it with
the [ __ ] good shrimp the good shrimp
cutting the shrimp so the problem is i
pay 1605 a pound for that shrimp yeah 13
if i get it by the pound 12 i know the
guy this shrimp i'm gonna get for three
dollars a pound
so
yeah
the way i'm gonna tell my employees i
gotta fit nine dollars a pound and i'm
gonna skin six dollars off the pound
right there not to mention nobody's
gonna know about the katrina oil with
the crab legs and guess what like my
shit's gonna come fortified you're just
getting shrimp for 16.50 i'm giving you
a little bit everything seaweed
a duck leg you know what i'm saying one
frozen duck
who is eating this a monster me you're
eating when i go down to [ __ ] pop a
dozen you ask for
give me a bowl of [ __ ] gumbo i eat
out lastly leave sat right next to me
right now all the seafood and then you
look at it and the gumball water's brown
but it's got that little streak that's
just olive oil it's not [ __ ] horrible
it's like this little i know [ __ ] it i
listen i grew up in jersey you know in
jersey got that algae in the water yeah
okay kind of greenish okay i'll buy the
shrimp okay no i don't want you
okay i want you to go to pop with those
because
when you eat that shrimp
it builds and builds character
cancer it builds your immune [ __ ] the
cancer we froze the shrimp the cancer's
gone the cancer's gone we cleaned the
oil off what do you think that good
shrimp didn't
swim in some of that [ __ ] that was left
over
radiation from russia radiation from
japan i just came here to talk about
comedy i know but we gotta talk about
reality here where's tony bennett cox
sucker that's what the problem is
that's the problem we didn't go to
papados it was too far we went to sushi
roku which is horrible
it was terrible we ate i ate so much
but it was terrible i love you with all
my heart who eats [ __ ] sushi in
phoenix
to pick up the pieces
i didn't want to insult you
oh my god i have to go when do you have
to go i gotta believe by nine
how long have we plotted for perfect
where you going to be at the next couple
weeks pumpy dates and you're going to
bring abandon ship well i don't want to
i don't have how long have we been on
the podcast for about an hour okay
uh
my tour starts um
november 4th let's talk about the
netflix special when did you tape this i
typed as i think in may when april in
chicago with the vic okay and it came
out about three weeks chicago's a great
comedy audience i love them to death and
yet you can't play downtown for more
than a couple days because the zany's is
so small great club so small
um disagree so that's it and then it
came out and now i go on tour
what do you want to know i want to know
what city is he doing on this [ __ ]
tour of people it starts with like
milwaukee if you go to eliza.com it has
all the cities and i have to look up
well here i can go to elizabeth
i have it right here what what cities
are you excited to go on like all of
them
people always ask that there's some
cities i haven't been to i've been to a
lot of cities i'm excited to go where my
fans are i don't care if it's in the
middle of
abu dhabi which is fine now actually
that's not a bad place to go uh i don't
care if it's the middle of like the
sudan like as long as there's fans and
there's red bull i'm happy to go it goes
uh philadelphia sorry it starts in
milwaukee madison philadelphia i'm very
excited to go there uh washington dc
haven't played there st louis atlanta
love it nashville love it seattle great
san francisco tahoe for new year's the
day before new year's eve houston austin
dallas boston
mashington connecticut for foxwoods i'm
sure you've played that and i'm here in
l.a at the wheelchair e-belt for for
valentine's day
and those are just the that's the tour
so it's a lot
but not so much that it's hard
i love you i know you work all the time
and i got a lot of respect for you i
work because i don't have a family or a
day job
well i know how hard it is you sure you
do i got a lot of respect for you i'm
really happy you came on because it
meant the world to me because i want
people to know you're a bad [ __ ]
they know they kind of know but now it
solidifies you came in i'll take it you
know what i'm saying you almost say to
stop but you thought about your future
you looked at the mushrooms and you said
joey i did them once and it [ __ ] me up
and i then again i had a good time
that's the other thing i'm afraid you
could take them when you go home do you
wanna hear your secret good actually no
i don't wanna say that because then i'll
because here's the thing when you're a
girl and you share stuff on podcast then
people forever tweet at you about it the
last time i was stoned
i was intimate with my boyfriend and
horrible
violent weird thoughts went through my
head which is not what you want when
you're like naked with someone so i just
don't i don't think pot is for me not
for you do you drink yeah
but i still gotta yell at you about the
[ __ ] sushi in phoenix
it wasn't my fault
let me yell at you first and then you
can yell back i did it was the only
thing that was open you were in the car
with us we were looking at all these
things on yelp nothing was open because
of the time we got drunk
you're [ __ ] off too he couldn't drive
yeah drive oh i gotta go pick up dave
like dane's got a helicopter [ __ ]
take me to pocket house and it was
everything was closed sushi roku because
it's kind of like a douchey party town
was open and i was like fine i am a food
douchebag that's how much respect i got
for you i did not [ __ ] up your night
yeah because there used to be the tempe
improv
and the sushi place opened up downstairs
yeah do you know how many comedians got
sick in that sushi place the hospital's
sick wow
that's why joel partnered with was it
copper kettle what is it called copper
blues so tasty
so tasty steak bites
you like the cup of blue i like steak
bites i love it i eat garbage they got
good steak bites i think they've got
great some of the impressive steak bites
if it's a joel bash cough improv they
might have steak bites
that's what you want steak bites you
know i i i worked with joe the first
night he started oh yeah 98 in miami i
came in for new year's
and he had just [ __ ] started the
clothing store went out of business yeah
and now he was in the comedy but he knew
nothing wow he was just a young kid and
we used to giggle and [ __ ] 1998 so this
is 15. so to see him at yeah [ __ ]
oddball the night joel is a manager now
he's an owner he's the owner of several
improvs they just opened one he
consulted him won an oxnard really good
guy always been super cool to me
you know i think a lot of especially for
women in this business it's like someone
tried to sleep with me and they were
terrible
i know the difference between like
no he's very respectful
he always treated me like a colleague he
always brought treats for blanche
uh a lot of cl i've never had a club
owner be a piece of [ __ ] to me because
it's like well look at the numbers or
even when i wasn't doing great numbers
like they were always
for the girls listening it really is
about the way you carry yourself
so
treat yourself with respect and they
won't treat you like garbage
that's my big lesson of the day
i saw i'm a big shark tank fan and i saw
a clip with barbara they're like the one
i don't like the other the younger lady
laurie i don't like girdle why don't you
like laurie
i like laurie i don't like them all i
don't like the uh the the the uh
infomercial thing and i i don't know it
could be just because she's younger that
could be it but it just comes off weird
her mr wonderful very she's older than
you oh yeah obviously okay but uh not
that obvious well yeah that's true okay
but
i really like barbara was with uh she
was doing something on like abc news or
something and she was saying that
she thinks that women should act like
men like that's like when it comes to
business because
in her business in all businesses women
real estate like women don't ask for
raises at like a crazy percentage and i
should have written it down
don't ask for raises but men do oh and
well it's hard to relate to that as a
comic because it's different because i
ask for more money all the time and it's
not me asking for it it's my agent on my
behalf but barbara corcoran's a [ __ ]
business animal uh if you watch the last
10 minutes of my netflix special it's me
reenacting an episode of shark tank
and uh it's my favorite show so
yeah just saying put that out there i
like the blonde and i like the they're
both bond the older lady barbara
corcoran of the corking group and laurie
grinier of qvc i like uh they're all
great they aren't cuban i always learn
something when i watch it yeah i like
mark cuban i look at the people i go the
balls on these people oh my god and some
of the ideas yeah just something
sometimes you know that they're on there
because the idea is stupid the worst
idea on shark tank ever and this is 100
googleable go to a website called is it
we google it yeah man medals
this guy i one thing i don't like is
emasculated men as a woman like i seek
to be powerful not to make anybody feel
like [ __ ] and this guy gets out he's
like my wife would always ask me he's
like terrible looking to take out the
garbage and when i would she'd be like
what do you want i met all so that's
what i came up with manmedals
here's a picture of my balls in memoriam
and it's a medal that you give your
husband when he does a good job at
something
they're like five dollars a piece
there's no way they have any online
sales look at these look at these
[ __ ] pieces of [ __ ] 25 bucks go into
the earth and just make garbage
wait read them best hobby the best hubby
ever
two dollars coming home to be a daddy
five dollars yeah you come home to your
kids so you get so you get a medal i
emptied the dishwasher i asked for
directions i yeah like was it 1950 i
picked dirty clothes up all right what
is it the toilet paper put the toilet
paper roll up or like if you've married
a total [ __ ] person totally [ __ ]
total [ __ ] i don't want my wife
isn't this insane
it's it's because of aggressiveness
these are the people that vote for trump
you understand why people go how's trump
getting there who buys britney spears
albums there's always that question i
went to a britney concert did you know
but there's always those people who she
sells 30 million who someone's doing
somebody's doing someone's doing it
anyways there's some mom medals too
i don't do coco i don't do coke so
somebody's buying 30 million
metric tons of coke a week in this
[ __ ] country they're cutting it with
katrina shrimp and they're cutting it
with katrina shrimp like a [ __ ]
if you could think of it
and it's building immune systems
you heard it from your doctor joey let
me read this shout out to you and we'll
get you the hell out okay me and leo
close it up i want to thank
fancy yancy glass with a beautiful pipe
i want to thank fire goddess beth and
her beautiful husband for coming to the
shows it was great seeing you
mad cordis
tully [ __ ] one
alex cleary one by one podcast [ __ ]
shakes and john culler
what up [ __ ]
all right
well thank you for having me yeah no i'm
very excited that you came in
okay bye and uh thank you thank you
and go to netflix go to netflix
conf what are you listening to outside
yeah i think the cops are here cool uh
it's confirmed kills on netflix and you
can also check out my show forever31 on
hulu
yeah thank you and what's the forever 31
about i don't even know about this [ __ ]
it's a show uh i have a show
it's on hulu and abcd which is abc's
digital platform like nbcsc so abc is
abcd it's a show i have eight eight
episodes called forever 31 it's just a
show about me
my life you're 31. what was 31 when i
pitched it i'm 33 now all right thank
you good for you man you're a little
working savage i'm a savage a baby
savage all right go take blanche bye
guys thank you thank you thank you
for the bottom line you were real savage
thank you you're the best device
boy i have to walk out in the dark
yeah yeah leo run out there with you
i'll sing a song for these people if you
want there's a door uh right next to the
thing oh [ __ ] she didn't park inside no
oh oh no there's a door there's a door
hold on just leave this door open i'll
watch you there
love you stay black and be careful
there's nobody out there all right
there's a couple of black dudes they
just sing song
not afraid of black people thank you
there you go
they'll give you leave the door open
check it just in case
leave that door open the door is right
by that gate there
what's up lisa yeah ooh how was your
little weekend brother i had a good
weekend i did ask it again i know you
did what did you think
it was a and you didn't leave the
[ __ ] house i didn't leave the house
uh because paul was there so i didn't
want to i didn't want to like abandon
him no you should have taken her with
you that's what the acid
the most important thing about acid
i don't
this is where acid is different from
like
uh
you know ecstasy and all that stuff i
haven't done that yet no no and i'm not
saying for you to do ecstasy
when we do acid in the office when we
eat a mushroom
it's fun for two hours but the reason
why we don't really have fun
is because we don't go out and have
contact
like i'm scared too i had a question
about that what i was gonna go out but
then i got a little paranoid because of
my eyes because your eyes really do get
super dilated doesn't matter people
don't look at that people don't notice
no no you're not gonna make eye contact
what do you think people out there
hypnotizing yet tonight but i'm making
eye contact
uh
don't i wanted you to go to a a diner
yeah i wanted you to go to a
a starbucks at 10 o'clock and just sit
there for 10 minutes
and
look and listen
and you would go home and go i'm never
going to stomach again man those [ __ ]
people here they do something you see it
for what it is well that was my question
and i think you told you gave me the
answer today
you you asked me if i smoked anything
and i didn't i took a bunch of stars it
took like almost a thousand milligrams
it's time for a star okay um
but
like it didn't get as deep
as that i have in the past like there
was some color stuff like the ceiling i
really like my ceilings kind of textured
i don't really know what that's called
and it kind of swims that's really fun
to look at but it didn't really get to
that next level and i think you're right
i think i should have smoked
yeah because the smoke it when you smoke
every hour it rekindles the acid and
then you start going to yourself
i'm not high no more that [ __ ] joey gave
me sucks and also you look at the wall
and you get caught looking at something
you're like [ __ ] that i'm high
and by you smoking it makes the
transition down a lot easier i'm happy
you did it i mean i love it i really
like it i can understand why people when
i went home that night
it's really funny when i went home that
night
i fell asleep but i was still tripping
it reminded me of the night my mother
died
i fell asleep
but i was still tripping
and what was really weird was
that
i kept thinking about my options
that night so we did it wednesday right
i was leaving thursday morning okay
the alarm was gonna go off at 4 00 a.m
no
the alarm went off at 3 30 a.m
okay
we got home at what time and we did the
podcast at three i think you went home
by like six well you were right you went
to dinner i think no i went and picked
up mercy okay yeah right i went and
picked up mercy and we went home
and
we i was sitting
there and by seven o'clock i couldn't
take them
i wasn't high no more but between the
the [ __ ]
edibles we took and the weed
i was wiped out you know i had gone for
the blood test
that morning
did i go for the blood test that yeah i
think so and i'm like should i get on
the plane
if
i got kidney damage should i get on the
plane of this vertigo
should i get on a plane to columbus ohio
if all this shit's going on
and i laid down that night at [ __ ] 7
30.
i go let me go to the room put the fan
on
and just take a nap and next thing you
know
it's 3 30. it's three in the morning and
i'm waking up before the alarm and i
wake my wife up i went out first
put the coffee on
and in that time period i thought about
because it was a connecting flight
first or was at 4 00 am but it was a
great flight
it was a great flight it was at 6 00 a.m
i didn't have to leave at five anymore
right it was six a.m and it got me an
hour later and i got early
so i went to lay down with all this [ __ ]
in my mind
about should i leave
what's [ __ ] up my back
uh
there was like three or four questions i
went to bed with and when i woke up at 3
30 they were all answered
see that's my favorite part about acid
was the thing and but that was my
problem with at least this time
wednesday wednesday i did
it's kind of it's almost kind of scary
like it's almost like i'm
a little speeded up and it is speed i
guess but it's like i i my i was joking
that my neighbors must think i'm crazy
like once a month because i just walk
around my apartment all night
i just like i walk and i talk to myself
that's whenever you call i'm walking
around my apartment that's just how i
think
so welcome to your partner i don't know
that's just how i think so that's what i
do on acid but it's like kind of manic
it's like you kind of zoom you do a
little bit of the dishes and then you
run around there
but that didn't happen this weekend so
that was a little bit of a bummer but it
was
a different experience it was i didn't
get as anxious
as i normally do
which is crazy to me that you don't get
anxious on this when you do these sort
of drugs
no
i used to get anxious
off the stars
or often edible
when i first did a higher dose
every time i took a higher dose i would
dose myself knowing
that this was it put yourself through
your own training yeah like one of these
doses
when that time i took the 500 in san
jose okay that was the biggest dose i
had ever taken
and i only really took if you think
about it i only ate 400 of that
wow because i didn't eat all day it hit
me immediately
yeah it did and the travel time was a
little faster than you expect
that's when i get anxiety
every time i make a jump like when we
ate to 1200 that night right there was a
minute during the [ __ ] podcast or
during the periscope where
like i got to catch myself
that means it's hitting me that means
that i have to stop and think if i'm
gonna have a heart attack or i'm gonna
get up and jump off that [ __ ] balcony
like for a minute there i got to like
catch myself like what am i doing with
my life and all of a sudden
pilot to bombardier and i come back so
what happens to you
after you've already done it yeah see to
me
and this is the same with my life
all of my anxiety is before something
once i make a decision
i'm fine with it but me making a
decision
is
it it's like pulling teeth it's i hate
it
and i'm trying to work on it but it's
still it's it's hard
that's where i have all my anxiety
that's good to know [ __ ] up thank you i
appreciate it
i did kettlebells today that was fun i
ripped my [ __ ]
hand
i've never torn a callus before look at
you you're getting callouses and
everything 28 years old you finally got
a cat with that i've been callouses for
filming
since you've been doing those
kettlebells you're getting a cat you've
never heard from dave huh no not really
not recently that's it
he wants his own wife that's something
he don't want to do it no more
oh we're doing more no i took him out to
give him to the [ __ ] blench
yeah i took them all
now columbus was great i've seen some
great people in columbus fire
i want to give a shout out to sam baker
he showed up
a couple great [ __ ] people showed up
i'm not remembering everybody
i just want to let people know i had a
really [ __ ] good time
this week as you know i go to [ __ ]
chicago it's already sold out i mean
thursday night tickets were available
i'm a little nervous i'm a little
anxious one thing i do know as i did the
work
uh
you're confident in the material
well
i had to
after last week at oddball i felt that
my because now i didn't go out in front
of people listen to the podcast
i went out into a general
audience right yeah
and my material wasn't totally offensive
but it was
uh
out of the the realm but it's the
oddball festival so they knew i was
coming at him they knew somebody was
coming at him
i didn't get the love that segura got
and ali wong and those people i didn't
expect it
but one thing i learned was that i had
added more humanity to my set
so to balance out the craziness yeah so
when i went to
uh
columbus i had five really different
sets they were all basically the same
but i didn't do a lot of jokes a lot of
nights
you know it was kind of weird
and i just spoke about
different things that i just wanted
people to know you know this is my first
special it's introducing myself to
united states people going to watch this
on ciso
i don't want to go out there and do the
same dirty [ __ ] i've been doing for 20
years i want them to look and go okay
this is all right but at the same time
i want to tell them a little bit of a
story
and do material a little bit of story
and do material and the stories and the
stories about me
you know should i tell them that i you
know i got like i tell them right last
weekend in columbus there was two shows
where i talked about kidnapping to
somebody
and i got locked up and i told him the
story about trump
you know just
to break it up just to see if there's an
angle in there
i spoke about bidets that the days are
really making a comeback and that people
you know they have the cold water ones
and the hot water ones you know i'm
saying
cold water ones is tremendous the hot
water ones put you in another [ __ ]
plant did you install your bidet oh yeah
what do you think oh the cold water it
does it does wake you up a little bit
but it's i love it how fast does it go
in your muffler it goes pretty fast
there's a little knob on the side to do
levels but it's great what level did you
put it up you know what i don't know i
just i just kind of do it to the side i
don't i didn't look at numbers
yeah i installed it with paula this
weekend it was great it took like 30
minutes okay because you it comes with a
little adapter and you know that little
tube behind
and only took 30 minutes because i'm i'm
i'm terrible at this stuff but it's just
a little adjustable install in my
outdoor bathroom there oh yeah you
should
it's i'm excited to try the warm water
one but the cool and but here's the
reason why i love it
because
i i'm a big guy i sweat sometimes
i don't sometimes i don't have the time
to take the afternoon shower
but there's nothing like
there's nothing like feeling like you
have to take a shower because of that
and this just eradicates it it's amazing
i hate running that so once i know i
have it like i feel like my ass is
burning or something i'm like that means
i got rotten ass coming i can't go out
that night so i just take a complete
shower but with the bidet yeah you could
take a dump
and then wash your muffler in the back
of your nut sack oh because that's what
the fungi nailed them you do the backing
you're nuts why not you're there
in case you show up to a party what's
the somebody suck your nuts what are you
gonna you're gonna have a clean ass i
haven't tried that it's not
and once you're down you might as well
clean the nut pull the skin back and
wash the helmet a little bit are you
turning around and like no right there
like you're standing there in your
toilet right right the bidet night now
you just move back a little bit and put
the water on a little bit more powerful
and let it hit the back of your nut sack
all right
you get yourself a stack of little rags
you put them next to you like get like a
washcloth okay and cut those in half oh
my goodness you see what i'm saying like
i got the artist what the [ __ ] do you
think you're dealing with it and then
okay but what do you use that for just
the balls
once the muffler is clean because you
what are you gonna do just let the water
hit it you gotta stick your hand there
like a savage or something with a bar of
soap
right you just
let water hit it and [ __ ] it and just
hit the muffling with you your ass was
gonna smell like [ __ ] and water
that's true i i didn't think about the
soap come on but then but then you're
sticking like soap up your butthole
tremendous
tremendous somebody stick their nose in
your butthole and i was like dawn
you know what i'm saying you get some of
that liquid detergent so this is like a
three-step process is what you're saying
i'm talking about if you're gonna go for
broke go for broke right
how are you just gonna wash your butt
with hot or cold water you gotta have
some type of when you take a shower you
have soap right absolutely and you put
in your muffin right all the time okay
then what what are we talking about but
i have a loofah in the shower okay so
you take that little luffy you put like
uh let's say you're gonna kill somebody
you wear those gloves you're gonna say
you're gonna stab somebody
you wear those [ __ ] uh work gloves
right yeah yeah
latex gloves all right right and you
[ __ ] uh
put a little let the water hit your
muffler and while it's hitting it
you take a little cleanser and you put
that in your butt and mix it up with the
wash raw and massage your little muffler
and then through the back of your nuts
through the whole nut sack and move
around let the water hit your nut side
and then you pull the skin back on your
helmet and you dip it and let the water
hit that and you clean that off with
your helmet that's a little puerto rican
wash right there and you take that
washcloth and flip it over
drain it in the sink and then wash
around your helmet
at least you're clean
this porter tub if i was a hooker i get
a porter tubby i get what what's it
called hello tushie.com
what the [ __ ] you think you're dealing
with you this is for people who are uh
active down there this is for this is
for
anybody
who likes having a clean butthole like
and they were saying and this is great
for me
paula uses and just girls use more
toilet paper than i've ever seen this
this is going to eliminate it like they
they say it reduces toilet paper usage
and it's just it's it just feels great
you know what man i'm happy that you
installed it
because i thought my wife was installed
this week and she was like no oh you
could even do it i promise you you know
i could do it i know i could do we've
been talking about this bidet the day
we're talking about you can find them on
hellotushy.com
i mean but days are back i even looked
it up
that more people building homes with
bidets again but there's a device that
sprays your butt clean
with clean water okay you can't beat
this you can have cold water or hot
water i grew up with a bidet in my house
they're tremendous my mom had it in her
own little bathroom i would sit there
because these are the the days are
either self-standing but not everybody
has ten thousand dollars to get a
plumber to come over to the house
that's why
hellotushy.com they got the answer
thanks to their sleep bidet it clips on
to the existing toilet and it sprays
your butt completely clean with fresh
water to get your mufflers sparkling
and now when you're sitting there you're
not getting bacteria growing and you
know hemorrhoids and yeast infection and
just plain old rotten ass listen you
take a [ __ ] dump at work you're
sitting there at lunch time what do you
think cultivates in your [ __ ] by five
o'clock wait did that smells good
there's a party down there now no
so i'm not saying that you're at work or
whatever once you're home
why not treat your muffler the right way
on the weekends or whatever the hell
you're at home
hellotushiga.com got the answer all
right not to mention like lee said but
days are better for the environment no
paper more trees you get yourself one of
those little like i said you go to bed
bath and beyond or costco you buy 20 of
those little towels and stuff like that
you just can't spray your muffler you
cut them in half you fold them
and there you go hellotushy.com
in full [ __ ] effect
each [ __ ] is a pint of water all
right
and let me tell you something tushy
stands behind that product
for 30 days so do me a favor you heard
lee talking about it this is a
tremendous
stocking stuffer for grandpa grandma
anybody who takes it in the muffler
part-time
this is the one you need go to
hellotushy.com right now they're going
to give you a deal and a half i'm going
to give you a 10 off so go to
hellotushy.com right now slash church
c-h-u-r-c-h
to give you 10 off delivered to your
house who's better than you this is the
stocking stuffer you need so go can you
imagine everybody goes to holland
everybody goes to these people's houses
for thanksgiving and they bring
a pumpkin pie can you imagine you show
up to somebody's house this year with a
portable bidet
who's going to get invited to everything
in the next couple years you [ __ ]
go to hellotushy.com right now slash
church also i want to thank my main
[ __ ] who listened
yesterday i did not fall asleep this is
the second week of the ride i did not
fall asleep i took a plane
i got home i played with the baby and i
stayed up for a while you know why
alpha brain [ __ ]
it eliminates the jet lag you understand
me eliminates it completely not only
that you focus i take the alpha brain
before i get on the [ __ ] plane now
i get off the plane
i get home my wife's not home they're
both at church i [ __ ] dump my clothes
i write up my following week report i
take a shower i put away my plane
tickets and my receipts and the [ __ ]
paycheck and the pay stub and how much i
paid at the [ __ ] airport for parking
and then when the baby comes i play with
them i eat with my wife
and once the baby goes down i go to bed
and i wake up at five and i eat with him
i take three hour [ __ ] nap and
because of the alpha brain i got no jet
lag and that's the truth ruth do me a
favor on it's got a great supply of
products whether it's the hemp force
or the new mood or the shroom tech or
the mct oil they're rocking and [ __ ]
rolling okay
they also have bats weighted bats and
kettlebells and all that but i can't
help you there all i can help you with
with the supplement side go to honor.com
right now take a look at the great
selection if you see something you like
that you want to try
boom put it in the cart and press in
church and get 10 off your first order
delivered to your house all right they
also have to stay on it program where it
gets delivered to your house
automatically it's a tremendous [ __ ]
website it's a tremendous product i live
on it go to honda.com right now
and press in church boom go to
hellotushy.com right now and press in
charge and get 10 off all right
anything else you want to talk about lee
you're excited about going to chicago i
can't be more excited i couldn't be more
going to portillo's thursday night with
people shake oh yeah it's friday i'm
hooking up with my main man josh passini
over there and [ __ ] chicago
10th planet very cool eddie bravo's
flying in so he'll be at the show's
friday night
you know he's upset because he couldn't
come in saturday i couldn't put him
anywhere so everybody's just going to
come in friday and thursday night a lot
of people coming in thursday night great
yeah it's uh it's an honor to be a part
of it
no no i'm happy that you're coming this
is hey listen
25 [ __ ] years people
25 [ __ ] years do you really [ __ ]
think i ever thought i was going to
shoot a special
i mean in the beginning i always thought
it would be an hbo special that's all i
ever wanted
when i shot that thing that's on
showtime the piazza comedy slam
if you knew about anything in my life at
that time i just took the money and ran
i didn't think that thing was gonna
happen
when that thing had you know how bad i
felt
because i did a [ __ ] 40 job on it
not to mention i look like a [ __ ] bum
i just did the set to get the cash to
get the [ __ ] out of the new coke
you know everything i've done early on
was because of the cash that's why i
didn't work out this is the first time
i'm doing this because
i think i owe it to myself you know i
owed it to myself you know and i worked
hard the last four years at the stand-up
[ __ ] not to mention the 21 before that
when i lived in a car and [ __ ]
took cell phones back and [ __ ] uh you
know i took a big chance in 1995. this
makes it all
even now i don't want to kill nobody no
more
i'm fine i got a daughter i got a
beautiful wife i got a great friend in
you
i got great people around me here and
i'm about to do something that was a
[ __ ] long shot
in anybody's life never mind you know
what i had going on it was just
completely [ __ ] long shall we
so you know what lee
i'm not even [ __ ] nervous
i'm gonna deal with myself i'm gonna go
up there and do some material i'm gonna
tell some [ __ ] stories i'm gonna tell
some things that are going on in my life
and wrap it all up and get the [ __ ] out
of it
and that's it that's all i can do
everything else
i can't [ __ ] control
i'm lucky that we have the podcast
what the [ __ ] is going on tonight i got
like airport nine coming over everyone
coming in for the special they're all
coming in before no but it's
it's uh
i got i get the question a lot i used to
get the question why doesn't joey have a
special why doesn't joey have a special
and i i must imagine you got the
question or at least knew people were
asking it and that i mean
even though it must feel good that
people want you to have a special it
must hurt your feelings a little bit
that you didn't have one
not at all really no no not alone
listen man i i was
i'm very [ __ ] lucky to be here
i always
kept that in mind especially
after the longest yard
i realized what had happened
well you know
sheryl crowe
has an album
i think the second album chevrolet crow
has is a really great album
and there's a song on that
i don't know what the song is
and she says most people quit
before the miracle happens
when i was shooting along his yard i
kept hearing that lyric over and over in
my head
because there was so many times before
that i was gonna quit
and i kept thinking about
when
for the first time jesus [ __ ] christ
let me close this door
the only reason during the longest yard
i kept hearing uh
that lyric right you know
and the main thing that i kept thinking
about was 1987 when i had a semi [ __ ]
lively
and i wanted to quit to move back to new
jersey so i could snort coke with my
[ __ ] friends
i think from 99
to about 2000 or 2002
especially after joshua got his deal and
stuff
i got really sad inside for a while i
was like what the [ __ ] is going on with
me
i can't get arrested out here
but
it's like when you're making strides and
you don't even know you make them
i was making strides and i didn't even
know i was making them
because i was booking something
i was really alive when you book
something here and people see you
it makes them look at you differently
now now you're not a jerk off no more
you know what give him a spot dog he was
in that tv show yeah but it was a small
role it don't matter when was the last
time you did something
all right all right you know i wouldn't
say nothing
but people treat you differently you
start earning a fake respect
only shitty people would respect you
over a [ __ ] one line of the tv show
but it was interesting to see that i was
always making little moves
between you and me it wasn't the moves i
wanted to make at that time
i didn't want to be on tv
i didn't want to be in movies you just
wanted to stand up yeah but that's all
that was available to me nobody would
talk to me and stand up
at all
at all
the best i ever got was if you come to
montreal
in 1999
we'll put you up maybe for the dirty
show
and i was went all the way to detroit
and i said to myself what the [ __ ] is
wrong with me
what am i a [ __ ]
half a [ __ ] give me that one right
there
i go what am i a [ __ ] i'm gonna go
begging for a [ __ ] spot my mother
raised me better so i stayed in the
hotel room in detroit i went down to
coco's comedy club
i got an eight ball of coke
and i stayed in that room for three
[ __ ] days the last night mimi
gonzalez showed up and slept on the
floor a lesbian cuban lesbian chick
and we talked all night and then we ate
breakfast and she went moved to new york
city
how crazy is that i still remember that
type of [ __ ]
why didn't you just go back to l.a
who you
because
for some reason at the time i thought i
wanted to go to montreal comedy festival
and it wasn't until i got to [ __ ]
detroit i go
i'm not going to canada
i was going to meet somebody and we're
going to drive across to canada i was
going to take a bus to the montreal
comedy festival
oh so was your flight in three days is
that why you stayed
like that that was my question like why
once you decided you didn't want to go
why did you stay
one last day yeah i had nowhere else to
go okay i could have gone back to l.a i
had to be somewhere in the midwest the
following week
i said let me do an adventure
i got the money in my pocket let me do
whatever i had i had no money back then
in 1999 i probably had 300 dollars in my
pocket i thought i was johnny bananas
i'm in a hotel room that cost 42 a night
people getting stabbed next door to me
the towels are real small but i didn't
give a [ __ ] i was just happy to be in a
[ __ ] hotel room on the road doing
comedy dog
genuinely happy
genuinely happy
smoking reefer with a little cd case
with speakers
i was joe jerk off with speakers i would
write stupid jokes and go to these clubs
and i would go to any club back then i
didn't give a [ __ ]
i would look at the map if there was
four clubs in that town i would do four
[ __ ] showcases
and that's what i did i would go to all
jokes aside i would go to coco's comedy
club in detroit
this other place that they took me to
there's another place close to the
casinos in canada like on the michigan
border that i did when i was there those
three nights i made like i don't know
two or three hundred dollars when i was
there that weekend so i was eating good
i had a plane ticket to go back
to you know all i needed was a plane
ticket to go back to where i started
from those days so let's say i was
playing michigan
all i needed was michigan and a cab ride
to the hotel
and i'd put the rest together somehow
some way
[ __ ] crazy whoo look at his anxiety
thinking about only having three hundred
dollars in your pocket that's it no
money in the bank
i would put away like i would buy a
money order and put my ex-wife's
name on it for child support
and
he might be in the room snorting coke
and now i got the one i was worth the
money orders
and i wish i could [ __ ] sell him for
10 cents on the dime but i mean i was
it was crazy but that all disappears now
by me shooting this special
what makes it all better is thinking
about those nights in michigan when i
got attacked by the seagulls
what makes it all better is you know
being on a bus
from [ __ ] port authority in new york
city to
dallas
and it taken 24 hours and being on the
bus awake the whole time
watching people hi getting off the bus
eating lunch and smoking the joy and
getting back on the bus i got really
good at doing that i would roll like
three joints and
keep it in my sock and catch the cops
came on there and
[ __ ] crazinessly
being on the bus all night
like i was just
[ __ ] what am i gonna do i got no way
to sleep
i might as well be on the bus all night
do you think that contributes to you not
having anxiety about this
the fact that you went through all that
how about going in front of a judge
there's no more anxiety than that my
friend
going up in front of a judge and not
knowing the answer
that's [ __ ] anxiety
so this i'm taking it which i could look
at this two or three different ways
i could think of this is just gonna
change my life
i could think of this as this is gonna
get me a tv show
oh i could think of this i'm just going
to go up there and have a good time what
do you think of that
i think that i mean
do you think that's probably what you
need for a special because if you try
that overdo yourself you've watched a
thousand specials right
the funniest ones over there having a
good time oh hell yeah you have to and
the train when you watch bill burr he's
a great pro because he's having a great
[ __ ] time up there
and he throws something new into the mix
to make everything highlighted
that's the beauty about bill bird when
sebastian's on stage he has a great time
with that
when joe rogan's on stage he has a
phenomenal time up there
when when when [ __ ] aries on stage he
has a great time up there
for me to do well on stage i gotta be
having a great time
who gives a [ __ ] what comes out of your
mouth
this is my first special if it's an old
joke and it's flowing
[ __ ] it so be it [ __ ]
you know
i don't have a closer yet that's the
problem so i got three days to come up
when i closed i got a few ideas you know
what i'm saying i'm a [ __ ] idea manly
but i'm happy you're coming i'm sad that
a lot of people couldn't come you know
we couldn't get the extra
security wouldn't allow it these people
want a big insurance for the store they
don't trust
you know who's going to be in there and
how many people and they're going to
rent the store out in november
so this would be the 15th and then the
16th cleanup and construction starts in
the 17th so
it's been a nightmare but you know what
i can't worry about that [ __ ] i'm gonna
shoot my first special
thank you for all the love and the
support my wife made some [ __ ]
t-shirts
just to you know make him like a
commemorative i don't know what was left
she probably had like [ __ ] 11 left or
something
and the other ones are gonna get taken
to the club
leo be [ __ ] handing them out
shaking your hand and [ __ ] and that's it
and that's that [ __ ] i want to
thank eliza for coming on and giving us
that beautiful woman perspective that we
love here on the church
i love lee for coming on with his new
[ __ ] watch mvmt watching [ __ ]
big pimpin bam and that's it and that's
that you bad [ __ ] i i gave you
some shout outs i gave you some love
once again hello tushy once again
honored.com i want to thank the people
once again that came out for the
columbus [ __ ] funny bone
nothing but love for you [ __ ] i love
ohioans nobody gambles more than ohioans
i love you dirty bastards anyway we'll
be back wednesday i don't know if it's
today or night time i don't [ __ ] know
what we feel yet what do you think lisa
yeah what do you feel like doing because
we're leaving i don't know what time it
don't [ __ ] matter i think we should
let the spirit guide us that's right
tomorrow night i'm at the comedy store
it's the last no expectation tour
that's it and that's that
thursday i'm in uh zany's that's all
that's available and halloween weekend
here we go the south point casino
in beautiful las vegas 7 30 show friday
7 30 show saturday going back to vegas
uh vegas
vegas we're going back to vegas
we don't think so
all right we'll see you guys wednesday
night [ __ ] stay black uncle
joey loves you one more time eliza one
more time lisa how about you say another
star
i think i'm good on the stars
you're never good who cares
nine is a good number you know what it
is
it's russia it's uh yom kippur not yet
what time i don't know all right look it
up see what time you're on for boys
before we stop
let's see see you're bullshitting me i
have no idea when you open for us all
right tell me what it is right now
tuesday beginning the evening so it's
tomorrow night and it ends wednesday
evening perfect so wednesday but i'm
gonna i have to fast
i can't eat stars on rosh hashanah do
okay what do you want for this
going back to cali rosh hashanah
going back to russia
russia
going back to cali
there you go brother that's it we
celebrate yom kippur
tomorrow you got a bagel with lux boom
who's better than you some crackers
you send grandma birthday present
whatever even though he's the [ __ ]
purgatory
and that's it that's that i love you
[ __ ] stay black
thank you for listening for the church
of what's happening now without you guys
i'd have dick thank you lee hit it
[ __ ]
oh [ __ ]
mm-hmm